[Music]
Boop
oh my god guys we've made it to 100
there it is
episodes of the dojo I walked into the
studio balloons confetti everywhere you
know about good
that's the Asian side of you that got us
200 we want to thank Phil Byrne al
Madrigal forgiving us this great
opportunity I'm so much fun all things
comedy our producer Aaron Burr a hundred
by the way Patrick when did you join us
when did you jump in what episode prob
about nineteen eight but we Patrick has
been a welcome add to our show
absolutely Steve and I started doing it
solo we realized maybe the show is
jumping the shark a little bit so we
decided to bring in a cousin Oliver
which is Ted McGinley yes Ted McGinley
so I got to tell you it's hard to
believe that we have been doing this
almost two years absolutely crazy so I'm
excited by the way we have a great guest
on today's show we couldn't be happy my
god we're thrilled for our guest today
for the hundredth episode we have saved
probably our biggest frontloader for
today so we're excited and by the way
not only do we have a great guest for
today Patrick yeah but some great guests
on the horizon we have coming up in a
couple of weeks
Robert O'Neil that's right wrote that
great book about being the Navy SEAL his
experience yeah you shot Osama bin Laden
yeah I heard him on the Howard Stern
Show I was like oh my gosh we got to get
this guy so he's coming to do our show
happy to do it he said he's happy to do
it's a brand new book out what did the
guests that I'm excited about moving
forward Chris Hansen Chris Hansen amigos
Hansen we know him from previous we both
got caught up we can't get on talked
about it on air we know you know from a
previous joke of mine and he's into a
new season of a show called crime watch
daily
which is coming into its second season
this fall okay what we got a welcome to
the dojo episode number one number one
it's a very special episode and we
couldn't be more thrilled to have our
guest mr. Vince Vaughn is bigger than it
sounds yeah no thank you for making the
drive innovation here did you ever know
I can tell it's somewhat combative
there's an air of respect did you ever
think as a kid Vince that this would be
a career highlight for you coming into
this show a podcast originally it was no
gentleman's Joe Joe when I was a college
is no joke oh I think I didn't have the
imagination to come up with this
creative of a space to even know that
this could be a possibility had I
imagined the gentleman and we certainly
know that you have a new movie coming
out that you could go on Fallon and
Colbert and promote but why do that when
we're gonna push this thing to almost
for listeners there's no reason in your
defense when right here you're reaching
as many people as you can
there it is I like it well Vince thank
you so much for calling in obviously
let's just let's just talk right off the
bat about about your new film coming out
you have brawl in cell block 99 the the
director his name is Craig Zeller is
that is that the right way of saying it
yeah that's insane it's a it's he did
that movie bone tomahawk which is very
cool great and this is very similar you
know it's very character driven but then
it has a great action stuff and it's
very the violence and it is very you
know much more than you seen it in a
traditional movie so keep us together
they're very cool films yeah it's really
it looks amazing and the headline in
Entertainment Weekly says Vince Vaughn
is you've never seen him before
and you see the still and you look like
a badass the poster you look like a
badass there's a lot of violence in this
there's a lot of fighting in this you've
trained in the past as a boxer and Craig
is very complimentary in terms of saying
you know that you guys have I've had
shots where you're going you know 10 15
20 punches at a time in terms of
choreographing it how much did boxing
your your past and boxing play into an
attribute in this film well it helps you
know I had always boxed a little younger
just would go down to Train and you know
back then we used to spar a lot just
with other guys in the gym you know we'd
keep it under control but still we
didn't know anything about concussions
so I don't know how healthy it was every
day to kind of be sparring it definitely
helped me with this that I was able to
kind of when you do these larger
sequences are almost like dance routines
are very choreographed and when you're
doing it with kind of one camera or two
cameras and you're kind of capturing
everything at once you know it's all
sort of timing and stuff so so it was
fun to do that and I think it definitely
gave me at least a foundation to be able
to to prepare for the for the character
and how excited I must get to get off of
this subject which has been a great
subject let's talk about you gentlemen
Wow well I mean we're excited we we have
some great guests lined up in the future
we've had some great guests in the past
now we know you're a fan what's been
your favorite episode you know I think
it's a seat to you two I know how how
dare you like to rib see if I think it's
a feat that you guys have lasted a
hundred it's true physical fight in the
dojo that is true I mean because I I
will say the friends come up to me and
they say cuz you you've known us Vince
but friends will come up and say when a
Steve had enough that he just had enough
of you
jabbing and jabbing and making fun of
low ticket sales and this that and the
other thing and I there was a moment a
couple of months ago when Steve called
me on a Monday and I text him a bunch of
times never wrote me back and he finally
called me said can we talk sure what's
going on and he's like you know we're
gonna be friends forever but I gotta
tell you in Ohio you were being a big
pain in the ass that's like I get it
okay so we know it's good he
communicated positive saying that you'll
always be friends yes and then he gave
you the issues
guys are like a couple that's
successfully gone through therapy that's
the nice I'm glad to hear you're
communicating though I will say Sullivan
& Son which you and I met on was the
only show that I could ever do warm up
on and make fun of the cast as I was in
the audience no other show would I would
I could never be in the audience at Kohn
and be like hey look at that piece of
[ __ ] but yet I could do it at Sullivan &
Son and it was perfectly acceptable
nobody cared it was great you couldn't
do that a doctor can right that was sort
of a climate I would assume Vince bite
where you're getting ready to train in
these great boxing scenes he I
transitioned back to your movie you're
getting ready to train and I assume
instead of putting on like a great Fiona
Apple song you put on one of the dojo
episodes is that possible unis pumped up
keep an acidic Sierra critic tone in the
air make it make it make an atmosphere
where I realize that no one's safe you
fought in several films now what's the
most physically taxing movie that you've
done physically taxing this bra was
pretty physically taxing the last one a
hacksaw Ridge was physically taxing to
some degree just because of all the you
know gear and stuff and running around
and the battle sequences and stuff but
you know it's all it's all kind of fun
and ultimately and it's it's you know
always nice to be doing things that are
different and not repeating the same
stuff yeah what is the most physical
taxing break it up like like someone in
a cubicle you realize you got to walk a
little bit and touch your toes but I I
got a ask you because you're going
back-to-back with this director Greg
Zoeller your next film is dragged across
the concrete with Mel Gibson what is it
that obviously you guys have a chemistry
there's a rapport there what is it you
appreciate about him as a filmmaker to
go back to back and not only that to go
with a director you just work with
Gibson to go from working on one side of
the camera to the other side with him as
well well it's so hard to find him in
Craig's alders very unique in that he
was a novelist originally wrote some
great Western novels as well as some
others and he's had a full multiple
careers he was an animated animator
who's a cinematographer he just doesn't
cease to amaze you as far as the things
that he's allowed himself to get
interested in and he's kind of brings
them all together there's there's two
original songs in broad cellblock 99
that he wrote when he has the OJS the
band The O'Jays perform the songs he's
also in a band I mean it starts to feel
like the most interesting man in the
world
yeah but he's just he's a unique voice
you know what's interesting is he's he's
written a lot of screenplays throughout
the years and he would never take notes
he just really kind of investigates
things creatively and knows what he
likes and he would never compromise his
screenplays in order to get him made and
so it made it challenging for him I mean
he sat out for many years writing
screenplays that sold that were always
on a thing called the blacklist that
were like screenplays that were you know
kind of well-regarded in town that
hadn't been made and he just wouldn't he
just wouldn't take any notes or make any
changes it even believed in and talked
when they made the first Western bone
tomahawk when I heard the budget I
couldn't believe it this was a Western
with horses and stuff and they start to
believe for under two million dollars
and like in 21 days and when I saw it it
was you know very original filmmaking in
that the guy allows a pace that's kind
of lets you get to know characters the
acting is very subtle and understated
it's sort of a mash-up of genres and
it's just all kind of becomes an
original voice so Brawl when i read that
script was one of the best scripts i've
read and it sort of the movie has really
good character and performance moments
and then it has this element where the
fighting is sort of done almost kung fu
style although my characters that know
come through but the style of it is it's
got thriller and horror elements he's
just he's just very unique and so this
dragger cost concretes a really really
good script this movie will be released
by lions
the other the other movie brawl as well
as the bone tomahawk movie they're you
know they're longer than most movies and
I don't know that they would get neither
of them would probably get in our rating
their violence is probably more extreme
than that so it's harder for those that
get a traditional release this this one
drag will be rated R but I just find him
to be you know at a time where
everything's a sequel or people are
looking to you know push quote-unquote a
nighty through the marketplace he's
really taking his time and telling
character story so I find it very
interesting and fun to be a part of it
that is in the Vince the nineties when
you got your start that swingers movies
the Kevin Smith movies Wes Anderson
Damon and Affleck movies like all these
young careers where actors took it upon
themselves to write direct produce their
own project everyone seemed to like you
understood at a young age wow we need to
take this upon ourselves was that a
result of like frustration with not
getting the jobs you wanted not getting
enough work or did you guys just feel we
can do better like what was the impetus
for that yeah I guess you know I think
I'd like I think it's important to give
yourself permission to create stuff you
know there's something in being an actor
that you're sort of waiting and
auditioning for other material it's sort
of the nature of it but I think what
happened was we felt that some of the
material wasn't as it's hard I think
it's sometimes it's people of that age
who creates stories that are sort of
relevant for exactly what's going on
versus people who might be able to
summer move not not always but it feels
like if there's a voice of that age that
you can kind of write to what's going on
in the culture at that time and you see
it with stand-ups too like right now
there's a lot of great stand-ups and
they give themselves permission to write
and to do and perform constantly and it
sort of you know I always like you to
stand up if they have ambition to sort
of take it upon themselves to create
their own whether it's a television show
or film or something because a lot of
times people say all the stand-ups
successful people Tatel watch them let's
plug them into a script or plug them
into an idea but sometimes there's
something on organic about trying to fit
someone so unique you know into
something sort of general a lot of times
when the comedians themselves
involved in the actual screenplay and
right to their voice you'll have a
higher success rate I mean Woody Allen
you know as it was a stand-up right and
he sort of created Annie Hall in tons of
movies but he had such an interesting
point of view on perspective and you
know he was just using a different
medium to write so I think whatever
there's it's always I think good for
people to kind of create their own
happened and nowadays I feel like it's
so much easier just because you know the
equipment the ability to shoot things
it's a lot less expensive and more
tangible Vince would you consider Steve
a great stand-up Gary I would you would
I think Steve's really I've always
really been a fan of Steve we put him on
the Wild West thing there's something
very original just in his life
experience the way that he grew up and I
think he speaks to that so I think he
definitely has original points of view
on things and he you can't can't really
peg him as far as putting him in a
category he sort of has opinions and
ideas from different angles so I like
that I think whenever you watch him it's
always surprising to see where he turns
over he goes why do you think he can't
sell tickets Gary okay Vincent I got
somebody we can agree to dismiss is just
this is about a hundred I'm texting
right now from Ohio Vince you you
obviously started your career off with
some really dramatic roles and then you
made the pivot obviously I think because
people saw what you did in swingers to
being this great romantic comedic lead
and now you're making a pivot from true
detective to heart to a hacksaw to
cellblock 99 do you feel like your
careers kind of coming full circle back
to that serious dramatic actor if I was
saying that I'm it's quite because we
did swingers it was kind of it was
comedic but it was grounded you know
it's not a broad movie and then made was
another one that we did
that was kind of you know comedic and
you know but not so broad it was funny
because when old school came to me todd
phillips offered in the old school I
remember the studio hadn't done real a
lot of comedies they said all we don't
know if he can do comedy be funny
that's crazy because I just had done
them which I had that more kind of
dramatic stuff or kind of independent
stuff so that was interesting for me to
hear because I had you know kind of
started even doing improv and stuff
y'all curtain and then I think you know
I had a it started doing these comedies
and stuff and a lot of rated R comedies
which I enjoyed then it kind of shifted
in the things but you know I think
sometimes you get if something works or
clicks you kind of get they want to keep
putting you in that and maybe you kind
of get known for that and then it's upon
you to sort of try to expand that I just
got to a stage for me where I was much
more excited to try different things
doesn't mean I wouldn't go back and do
something to meet it if it was something
I was excited about but I'm gonna stage
where I have kids and I you know um
family so I have to be really excited
about a project you know in order to
want to go do it and and it's more just
trying to do things that I'm more
excited about I feel like I got into a
stage where I was kind of going and
doing some of these movies and I just
wasn't as conscious like I was going
into them and I maybe wasn't having as
high of a standard or a strong of a
point of view creatively um going in
that's that I wouldn't always do my best
and you'd be optimistic about the
project but I think I just have you know
developed into kind of higher standards
and wanting to selfishly you know try
different things you know cellblocks I
got to do something very different not
to work and have an accent you know
things that I haven't done it in a while
so I just enjoying kind of trying to mix
it up how many scripts are you presented
in a month I mean how many do you get
and see and how many are great how many
are junk I mean what's what's kind of
the thought I don't know it just depends
you know sometimes you get more scripts
than others but you try to give them a
chance
I remember you never know like brawl was
something that came to me that wasn't
overly on everyone's radar and I had
read it just thought this is terrific
and that's
sort of what led me to sing bone
tomahawk so you just never know when a
good script or an interesting filmmakers
gonna present it so Vince you've had a
an enormous career I mean decade you
know two decades now and there's peaks
and valleys obviously you've maintained
relevance but throughout the highs the
highs are always great but I've always
found that sometimes in failure or in
those in those valleys that that's where
you you gain motivation in terms of
moving towards that next project what is
was failure taught you over the course
of your career and how do you apply it
moving forward to the next project for
yourself or or continuing throughout the
course of your career
gosh as an actor or you know you know
Steve would stand up or anything oh you
guys know it's off most of its failure
right when you start meaning you have to
start to define till you're a success I
think differently hmm but as far as you
know most times you didn't get the part
you dog dish in you start off that way
it's very challenging so I think you
have to kind of define for yourself it
has to be about your own effort right
like the knowing if you did the best you
could and you were successful you could
do something and have it work but you
really didn't you know put your most
into it I don't know that that's
successful so I think it has to be
defined you start to learn as a you know
that you really successes
I guess that John wouldn't quote a
direct feeling you get knowing you did
the best you could to be the best you
could be at what you were doing so but
as far as dealing with things that don't
work or disappointments you know you
just have to keep moving forward
hopefully you learned from those things
but sometimes those things are worth it
if you know you're trying to do
something that's not necessarily such a
commercial shot you know it depends on
what your what you're attempting hmm
depends you know if you're trying to do
something you're looking to sell a lot
of tickets to or if you're looking to do
something that in your own mind you
think is interesting or value so but I
think you always learn more when things
don't go well that's for sure because
forces you to look at yourself or your
process I guess and there's a delicate
balance right of you know even being in
this stand-up comedian you got to look
at it but then you sort of have to have
a short memory to like you can't there's
a balance between learning from it and
then also moving on expecting it to go
well the next time so that we're gonna
kind of look at stuff but not not overly
dwell on it either right but there's
definitely a lot of learning going on
and stand up with the failure it's like
a quarterback throwing a pick six it's
like you got to get right back on the
horse
you know I'm saying Brendon you gotta
perform the next night or whatever so
you're you gotta have the balance of an
evaluation and a no analyzing stuff but
it can't be paralyzing all right are you
somebody to Vince that likes to go to a
movie that's opening that Friday and sit
in the back with the audience and just
kind of see what their reaction is to it
you mean my own movie yeah I don't watch
my own movies that much once or twice
this bra we'll see a few times because
we're going to some festivals the Venice
Film Festival in Toronto and a bunch of
festivals London so that's always nice
so that's fun to go in and be a part of
that and watch it in a crowd that way
but once you've made a movie you sort of
you know you spend so much time on it
you kind of you know you watch it you
don't really revisit it too much
I do like sometimes on opening night to
go out and sit in the back with the
audience in a crowd you know drive
around with some friends and kind of
check it out
and with comedies that's always fun
because it's you know such a such a
reaction and laughter and stuff so but
yeah I don't I may go early and sort of
check it out with a crowd but then I
sort of I don't really revisit it what
what movie have you done that you've
watched the most well I don't know I
don't think I've seen any of them more
than maybe oh wow three or four times
Wow
unless I was unless you know you'd like
I said you were going to festivals
there's things things like that but I
don't really watch them all that much I
don't know see if you watch your you
guys watch your stand-up special as well
nobody watches that scare
yeah that's organic it's funny though
stand-up is like when you're on stage
alone suffering it is like the scene in
Return to Paradise where you're yelling
at Joaquin going you are not alone right
now like he's about to die and like it's
your buddy in the back the only one
laughing and that's what is you narrated
the 34:30 on the Bears which was
fantastic is that something they came to
you with or do you make your interests
no yeah actually produce that movie as
well the about the 85 Bears and that
Jason the director did a great job with
that piece that was fun you know
obviously grown up in that area that
team was so important in my childhood so
it was nice to be a part of that it's
incredible because Mike Ditka won one
Jordan win six but but Ditka seems to be
so Chicago so much more than a better
steakhouse I think that's when you're
the first one enjoyed such a part of the
fabric and as you know as well too I do
think that team though that one year
with the Bears that was so many
personalities it was just such a unique
season there was there was just so much
intrigue to that to those personalities
between the fridge and Peyton and
McMahon there was just so many
personalities on that team how tough was
it to crack the story on the 85 Bears
because it's it's one thing to do a doc
on them but the angle that you guys took
in producing it and then narrating it is
it was amazing it's one of the best 34
30s I'm not just saying that it was a
credit really does go to the director
Jason who really came up with the game
plan on it but I think the point of view
was you know you sort of went through
this letter with with buddy and and you
know sort of you could see the bond that
these players had underneath that you
know which is something that you'd hear
about a lot but I think you got to
really see the investment that they had
in each other which was really moving
I got to ask you this is this is the
last question events
and I think this this might get a little
personal but I think we should air it
out here okay Pittsburgh Penguins have
won three cups the blacks Blackhawks
have won three cups I'm a Pittsburgh guy
your Chicago guy Pittsburgh did win the
Cup back-to-back and they have gotten
the finals one more time they did lose
it so they've gotten to the Big Dance
four times they won it three times I
would say on paper that the Pens are the
better team in terms of this generation
of players with tasing cane that tandem
and Crosby and Malkin Pittsburgh's
tandem what do you say I think it's
ready you might be a little biased
aren't you like on commercials for the
NHL doing the Roger Rabbit or the
penguin or something you know I take the
work I can get okay
maybe you I mean you're literally like
like dancing as if you're on the Mickey
Mouse Club when they're penguins so I
think you might be somewhat biased I
think they both have done a great job
both organizations I think what's
interesting is that the Blackhawks have
been fairly consistent I think the
Penguins won the first couple for the
Hawks along theirs and the Hawks had
been kind of consistent throughout where
the Penguins sort of won one and then
has gone through a couple coaches yeah
since then and this was more interesting
I think now is with this new coach Bates
they've won two and they want it
back-to-back so I think if you were to
look over that time span you'd have to
say the Hawks have been you know more
consistent and coach same core you know
Kessel's a new ad which really made a
difference I mean II I think he gets I
think the Canadian press is always a
little more bias in favor of Canadian
players you know not that not that you
know they're not great but I think
sometimes guys like Kessel who is
obviously just a clutch player and just
performs I don't know that he always
gets his do as much as he deserved but I
think if you look at the Pittsburgh team
right now
and over the last few years you'd have
to say to these last two years obviously
they dominated it but it's a it's sort
of a newer group and newer organization
was you know different chemistry they
had Iginla for a while
they brought in and they were sort of
wandering a little bit after that first
cup so I think they are really in a
great place now but I think the Hawks
have been from the time they've won
until this until this days they've
really been consistent they've they've
always been there and you know they've
never gone to easily except us last year
with Nashville and national turned out
obviously to go to the finals but the
Hawks have been pretty pretty consistent
but they look they both done well but I
think I think it's harder to evaluate
them because like I said Pittsburgh sort
of was off the map after that first one
for a good four or five years until they
kind of got reorganized Cheryl you're
fair I think that's the dream scenario
I'd love to see these two end up in the
finals but it is the hundredth episode
we cannot thank you enough for taking
time out of your day to call in and hang
out with us we really appreciate it
great to be with you gentlemen they're
in the dojo yes guys another hundred by
the way we're home the friendship to
stay intact did you really see Stephen a
rabid commercial like I'm fascinated
Steve no probably does stuff for public
access that we don't even know okay Gary
remember watching an NHL playoff game
and they were talking about how fans go
crazy and lovely and HL and then there
was my friend Stephen Joseph Byrne and
the pink jersey during the running man
oh okay what happened okay I'm
celebrating the fact that the Penguins
had won a game non-union Gary would
consider that a credit I think I was a
non-union gig I don't think Steve got
paid Vince thank you I didn't know
nobody doesn't have Gary to can't afford
cable
I can't afford something to look up now
no I can't watch TV Gary thank you so
much what is your goals for the next
hundred hundred episodes oh wow what do
we want to do friendship camaraderie
yeah just just the spirit of knowing
that somebody's got your back as I look
at Gary and I really hope that Gary at
some point ends up on Conan O'Brien show
it's so that I Anna late-night talk
shows yeah yeah yeah yeah
I think at the end of the day it is
funny Vince because as much as we jab
each other the minute we're alone and
it's just the two of us we do become
this very romantic like I could be
talking to Steve and you know
making fun of him harder than the minute
everybody walks away I'll be like I'm
really looking forward to in Tampa next
weekend with you you know I love you
buddy
well our generation that was always the
sign of a friend you could trust someone
who would make fun of you and make funny
publicly yes yeah that's like the
foundation isn't we all love graduations
gentlemen thank you very should continue
success thank you so much and we're
excited about your movie coming out next
month can't wait
take care about Vince Vaughn ladies and
gentlemen show number 100 there it is
the 100th episode of the dojo I mean by
the way I play coolers again it's so
great and I think Patrick is already
lined up somebody for episode number 200
so we're excited to get that guy come
2019 couldn't be a greater way to ring
in fourth episode yeah yeah yeah not
only just a great guy but like literally
like a national treasure I mean you go
out with that guy anywhere and people
just instantly oh yeah love them so
resizable all those iconic films and
that's that's a guy you could have on I
think for two or three hours and just
ask them until you bleed the rock dry
but what does we think the break-up is
the the fan favorite amongst women
that's got to be his movie the break-up
I mean he and answering that great on
camera yeah yeah that was fantastic
movie I got to tell you though like as
swingers just like the movie I think we
all kind of grew up watching like oh
that's that's it that you want to go out
with I mean I don't have doubts about
Vince new in comedy when they were doing
old school I mean he had does swingers
at that point it's like that's one of
the top comedies of the 90s you know but
there are comedy clubs that have doubts
that Steve can do comedy okay so what
was I saying made this film I made as
the film you got to go back and watch
cuz I remember watching yeah and I was
like man it's just kind of like he's so
grading on Favreau after seeing swingers
and I think you go in with these
expectations of a being like swingers
and and and if you go at it just know
it's a completely different film it's
[ __ ] hilarious and I think made is as
funny if not funnier than swingers
knowing oh wow you know even in a few
years after after seeing swingers you
know absolutely but we got to thank
Vince Vaughn for calling in yep
um 100th episode of the gentleman's dojo
now where can they find you online get
well they can find me at a canon comedy
there you go okay and keen at citizen
keen and on YouTube as well at Kean
economy let me just say this we are so
thankful that Patrick has jumped into
the go-go he's filled this third seat
nicely we did open auditions for months
trying to find somebody to fill this
chair yeah couldn't find anybody this is
the guy we picked his life changed
forever as a black lesbian it was good
to run in here to fill we are we are so
happy to have you know he's like he just
got divorced and she took everything
with the 5 o'clock shadow and the hair -
I know Patrick was our choice for the
third chair when he asked Jonathan Allen
if Hillary Clinton declared her
candidacy on SNL that's right here's a
man that does not do research by the way
a great episode that was so yes author
of shattered yes the story of the
Hillary Clinton campaign we've had a
number of great episodes and we cannot
thank you guys for listening please go
to iTunes rate us review us let us know
what you think of the show
these next hundred episodes we've
convened we promise we're gonna be get
you a better dojo than ever before these
things are gonna be great thank you to
the listeners thank you to Vince Vaughn
thanks to all our past guests Gary what
has been your favorite episode Wow Wow I
got a check I mean you know it's crazy I
know this one probably won't stick out a
lot but I really enjoyed talking to the
creator of yours revenge yeah I'm sorry
come over yeah cuz I love that grape
iakh growing up loving Atari I mean that
was one of my baby top-five 10 favors
we've had so many great well how about
you Kim you know I like the guy we
brought in who directed who directs
presently - not the Big Bang Theory Marx
a great energy
I gotta say Nick off the top ahead your
mom calling in probably my favorite one
first one I would say Peter Billingsley
because he's such a great friend and
then obviously getting two hundred and
having Vince Vaughn on I think Vince is
probably my favorite but by the way I'm
sure if we go back and look at some of
the ones we've done we would have
forgotten some of the just because we've
done so many forget that Oh
great this Gary Dean Kelly's Widow
Patricia Kelly she was fantastic what a
great episode
Lois was great Phil Lewis great great
television director and after himself we
had Dick Gregory and Jerry Lewis
scheduled for 4:00 yeah yeah well great
time to talk about death
pajamas dojo one on episodes Gary it's
been a pleasure working you all under 18
we are so glad to have you on board
thank you all for listening raid us
review us follow us thank you so much
[Music]